Alright, so we are starting the count.
We will start with the Eridura Reposado.
Yeah, the one bottle of Eridura Reposado still have that.
The bottle of Eridura Añejo still have that.
The bottle of Eridura Silver still have that.
The bottle of Eridura Blanco Original, the one on the box still have that.
The Eridura Legend, the one on the big like openable door box still have that one.
Still have the Quimador Cristalino, 100% Agave Azul Cristalino.
We have six bottles of Canoe Ridge Merlot.
We have eight bottles of Scarpetta.
And then we also have a 12 pack of Scarpetta bottles right next to it.
And on top of that we have a six pack of Squealing Pig Sauvignon Blanc.
Six bottles of those.
Then we have a whole 12 case of 750ml bottles of Windstorm Chardonnay.
Then we have a 12 case of Gearbox Pinot Noir Red Wine.
Then we have a 12 pack case, if you will, of Windstorm Cabernet Sauvignon.
Then we have three bottles of Windstorm Chardonnay.
Fourteen bottles of 30A Chardonnay.
Five bottles of the Shaker Red Blend.
Six bottles of Squealing Pig Sauvignon.
One bottle of Charles de Fer Prosecco.
Three bottles of Gearbox Pinot Noir.
Nine, excuse me, I was going to say 19 bottles, but scratch that, 11 more bottles of Charles
de Fer, plus the one other one we counted earlier.
Eight bottles of Marque de Caceres, spelled M as in Mary, A-R-Q-U-E-S, space, D as in
dog, E, space, C as in cat, A, C as in cat, E-R-E-S as in snake.
Fifteen bottles of Canoe Ridge Merlot.
Thirty more bottles of Marque de Caceres Brute.
Again, it's that weird kind of spelling one, but it's like, you know, it's equal with
the Charles de Fer, the Marque de Caceres, or whatever, is equal with the Charles de
Fer.
It's just like our Mimosa Prosecco.
All right.
So each of these cases is six bottles of 25.4 fluid ounce bottles, or it's a case of six
25.4 fluid ounce bottles of these stirrings mixes.
The ones we've talked about before, the Watermelon, the Margarita, the Mojito.
So this is how we get them.
We get them in cases of six bottles of 25.4 fluid ounce bottles.
So we have...
We have three cases of Watermelon.
Okay, so it says freaking 25.4 fluid ounces, but they're really just 750 milliliters.
And then we have four cases of Margue mix.
We have five 24-packs of Yingling, seven 24-packs of Michelob Ultra, ten 12-packs of Coors,
five 12-packs of Miller Lite, six 12-packs of Athletic, and a beer, two 24-packs of sugar-free
Red Bull, one 24-pack of regular Red Bull, one 24-pack of Watermelon High Noon, one case
of 12 bottles of the Marque de Sacere Cava Brute.
The same one I was talking about earlier, the Weird to Spell one.
And then we have seven bottles of this Carter's Lot Rosé.
Five Farmers Gin bottles.
Got a full case, 12 bottles of Pueblo Viejo.
A full case, 12 one-liter bottles of Wheatley.
Three
cases of six one-liter bottles of Crop Organic Cucumber Flavored Vodka.
Thirty-two cans of High Rise Pineapple THC Seltzer.
Sixteen bottles of Grenadine, one bottle of Jalapeno Simple Syrup, four bottles of Angostura
Aromatic Bitters, one 24-pack of Barrett's Ginger Beer.
Plus 18 more cans of Ginger Beers.
Plus 18 750-milliliter bottles of Watermelon Cocktail Mix.
Plus 20 bottles of Mojito Mix.
Plus 17 bottles of Margarita Mix.
Plus 16 bottles of Bloody Mary Mix.
Plus 13 bottles of Cream of Coconut.
Plus one bottle of Blue Agave Syrup.
Plus two bottles of Parrot Bay White Rum.
Plus two bottles of Crown Royal.
Plus 18 bottles of Pueblo Viejo.
Plus 10 bottles of Yave Blanco coconut tequila.
Plus 6 bottles of Casamigos.
Plus 14 bottles of Sieta Mysterios mezcal.
Plus 1 bottle of Milagro Reposado.
Plus 13 bottles of Milagro Silver.
Plus 11 bottles of Hendrix Gin.
Plus 5 more bottles of Farmer's Gin, Farmer's Organic Gin.
Plus 2 more bottles of Tanqueray.
Plus 5 more bottles of Crop Organic Cucumber Vodka.
Plus 4 more bottles of Crop Organic Lemon Flavored Vodka, 1 liter bottles.
And like the crop bottle, all the crop bottles, they're all 1 liters.
Just to be clear, 2 bottles of 1 liter Grey Goose bottles, 3 750 milliliter Grey Goose
bottles, 7 Tito's bottles, 3 Wheatley's bottles,
7 bottles of Crown Royal.
And those Crown Royal are on top of the shit I was talking about earlier, and that's how
we're going to do it always.
If I tell you a count of something at one point, the next time I mention a count of
something should be on top of the first one.
12 bottles of Meyer's Dark Rum, 5 bottles of Maker's Mark, 7 bottles of Jim Beam, 1
bottle of Tullamore Dew, 11 bottles of Fireball, 10 bottles of Jack Daniel's, 10 bottles of
Grand Gala, 5 bottles of Woodford Reserve, 7 bottles of Takeray, 12 bottles of Jameson,
12 bottles of Jägermeister, 12 more bottles of Wheatley's, 1 bottle of Chambord, 1 bottle
of Eagle Rare Tenier, 2 bottles of Nocello, Walnut Liqueur, 3 bottles of Tia Maria Cold
Brew Coffee Liqueur, 2 and 3 quarter bottles of Campari, 5 bottles of Aperol, 1 bottle
of Peach Schnapps, 12 cans of Susan Momwaters plus 8 more cans of Karen aka Lemon Blueberry
Momwaters, 15 bottles
of Parrot Bay White Rum, 9 bottles of Parrot Bay Coconut Rum,
18 bottles of Triple Sec of Mr. Boston Triple Sec, 12 bottles of Blue Curacao,
6 bottles of Romana Amaro, 11 bottles of Rumple Mints, 7 bottles of Bowls Elderflower,
2 bottles of Grand Marnier, 5 bottles of Campesino Silver Rum,
10 bottles of Caravella Limoncello, 2 bottles of Papas Pilar.
Alright so I paused the recording so this is low key like 5 minutes later and I'm at my truck
where I have a bunch more shit that we need to count including 1 six pack of these Mezcal
Siete Mestadios bottles and again those are 750 milliliters a piece just like they all are,
2 cases of Margarita Mix, 2 six bottle cases of Squealing Pig,
1 12 bottle case of Pueblo Viejo, 1 12 bottle case of Marque Caceres Cava Brute,
the fucking Prosecco I don't know the name of, 1 12 bottle case of Scarpetta,
1 more case of Squealing Pig, those 6 bottle cases of Squealing Pig,
2 more cases of Watermelon Mixer,
2 more cases of Margarita Mix, 2 more cases of Marque Caceres Cava Brute,